the men with guns haven't come to keep
the peace
they've traveled to northern mozambique
to wage war
the region has been terrorized by
islamic insurgents for the past three
years but these troops from rwanda
think they can wipe them out
can you defeat these insurgents
that is why we're here and we've already
indicated signs that they can
and will be defeated
there are a thousand rwandans here and
they've headquartered themselves in a
camp built by french firm total
the energy giant has sunk billions into
a coastal gas project but they fled when
the militants got too close
we're being taken for a tour of the
outer perimeter of the gas facility with
these giant three meter fences
and it does look like a real fortress
we moved inland with the troops and
found that dozens of communities had
been deserted
some eight hundred thousand in this
region have been displaced
but in a village called quelemagne there
were a few who'd found the courage to
return
is this a safe place to be
the military are here
they are all around us and we are
getting help we are safe we can eat and
we can communicate with the soldiers
but the rwandans won't stay here forever
and the insurgents know these
communities well many were recruited in
places just like this
you think they will come back
if you are old like me it's hard to tell
the difference between a villager and an
insurgent they all look the same
[Applause]
call themselves ansa al-sunam one of
many groups in africa who've pledged
allegiance to islamic state and deploy
their barbaric methods
the world recognized the threat during
the battle for palmer a town used by
many who worked at totel's plant
more than 200 took shelter in the
amarula hotel when insurgents invaded
the town in march
some guests tried to make a desperate
escape
and dozens lost their lives
you can see and you can feel the anxiety
and the terror that must have built up
within the walls of this lovely hotel
it's there in the bullet marks on the
walls and the ransacked rooms
and the roofs with gaping holes torn
apart by
fire the remains of the grenades
are still scattered on the ground
yeah clearly the insurgents had the
upper hand at the time
and
yeah they
their agenda was to make a very big
statement by killing its patriots
so they wanted for their presence
and they made their presence felt in the
city of moisimba de priya calling it
their capital after holding it for a
year
and the signs of occupation were all
around
the rwandans displayed the weapons they
had seized and they produced an
insurgent they had captured a young 18
year old who said he had been forced to
fight
rwanda says it will stay in mozambique
until the job is done
but few think this mission will last
indefinitely
john sparks sky news in muay simba de
priya